[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the public
space we continue our digging through
the rope I potus's of bill gayde with
the rope hypothesis sustained the ice
levels possible of gravity the black
hole this is what we will determine in
this episode titled lassoing black holes
bill gayde are you doing today
alright I'm joining us also is Peter who
has been challenging the theory last
time how are you doing Peter
excellent yeah I hope always well
alright guys it is my privilege as a
host to start with my own pet obsessions
today as I was thinking about this
episode I started dunking photons in
black holes just for fun just shooting
shooting photons at a black hole
gentlemen give me give me an idea of
whether that is a good thing to research
I've been looking at this basketball
ring and you know how sometimes we we
throw a ball and it doesn't quite enter
into it and it swings and it bounces it
it rows around the ring now it wants to
enter but it bounces out it comes back
in now here's the thing I've been
shooting photons at a black hole and the
same effect happens if I shoot the
photon air and it's of the correct
wavelength just the correct wavelength
to be as big as the the little circle
here of the black hole we get bouncing
photons don't we and from that from that
thinking not only do I predict that some
photons can pop out of a black hole
randomly I predict a prismatic effect
whereby the more you get deep into the
photon the more the smaller wavelengths
will be bouncing and therefore as you
dive toward a black hole I predict a
separation of the colors of light such
that as you enter it it's all blue and
then when you're in it's all red the
pits are what do you think
Wow okay so this is very interesting
you're competing here with Stephen
Hawking actually so I guess you're in
good company although bill gayde in it
probably is not too happy with that I
suppose but yeah it's interesting I
don't I don't have I had to I'd have to
unpack that in that choo Anna for a bit
who knew that basketball would one day
resolve the conflict between relativity
and quantum physics all right so let's
start with our subjects of today those
were my little minute min the rings of
the day as I was eating foie gras with
my girlfriend and just shooting photons
on my piece of paper bill gayde let's
talk about the challenge that gravity
poses a very high level to the rope
theory of physics can you introduce us
have you been thinking about it and what
is your take on how the ropes interact
at the black hole level well all
together I'm saying there's no such
thing as a black hole black hole is a
fantasy it should be taken completely
out of it's not it doesn't belong to
physics it doesn't belong to science
it belongs to religion 150 percent the
problem with the black hole that's where
we start problem with the black hole is
that we have no idea there's no
mathematician on earth who can tell us
what they mean when they say black hole
black hole is taken to be on one hand an
object and on the other one an abstract
mathematical concept and if you look at
that
the first 102 black hole object that I
sent you there yeah that one there nASA
says that it's that a black hole is a
great amount of matter packed into a
very small area it's a sphere they talk
about tiny they talk about small they're
referring to a little bowling ball of
black bowling ball or a black 8 ball
that's what they're talking about now if
you look at the next one do three
concept there the next one tub what is
it oh three Brown trying to move to it
I'm just having a little trouble yeah
I'm gonna go there all right
okay and that one there if you expand it
a little bit it says its treated by all
these people especially if you look at
the Max Planck one there it says it's
not a tangible object it's a region of
space-time or space or whatever and they
treat it as an abstract mathematical
concept so what's the problem the
problem is that half the world in math
treats it as a physical object a little
ball it says that star collapses or
shrinks over time to to this to the
point where it gets to be a little ball
black ball that's still floating in
space out there and the other half says
now it's an abstract concept this this
star completely disintegrated became
zero dimensional there's nothing there
and it becomes an opening and space-time
to another universe so so first we got
to determine is a black hole a black
ball or is it a hole in space-time is it
a region of space-time a concept or is
it a standalone black ball that's the
first problem we got resolved under no
solution because they have never been
able to be you know to to define that
and they never will well to that Peter I
tend to think that we all agree that the
black hole is just a region of space
that has extreme mass such that it is
very highly gravitational it is a point
at which the gravitation force is enough
to even even swallow light right I would
say that certainly that is the concept
the how it's normally defined I mostly
agree with actually in this case bill
Bill's prognost
agnosticism or whatever it is mastic of
the situation here regarding black holes
if you saw the the meme that I threw up
there I sort of give my two cents on on
black holes it in general where you know
you have the problem where you have you
cannot feasibly probe black holes at the
length and time scales
of the dynamic behavior that your truant
that you're trying to explain at least
at the moment so at that so as a result
it remains a topic of mathematical
speculation so it's it's I don't I would
not consider this in the realm of
physics as a result this is off it's
often considered cosmology perhaps for
example or or and it's highly
mathematical so well I mean I kind of
disagree if you both here Peter
everybody out there believes they have
been fed the story of the black hole and
there's not a single person out there
that I can find that will tell you oh no
black holes are speculative everybody
takes it as a done deal in fact recently
uh what was it a couple about a year ago
or so two black holes collide and they
said oh we can we have proven not only
that black holes exist that was taken
for granted but the fact that it created
gravity waves that reach the earth and
they got a Nobel for it and if you look
at the Wikipedia or you look at almost
any source they talk about a black hole
as a done deal there's there's no fine
print you know it's it's a done deal
I mean perhaps I don't know all the
details of this is not black holes are
not exactly my specialty as I mentioned
last time my specialty is in foundations
of quantum electrodynamics nonetheless I
would say that they once you put a label
on something such as a black hole it
tends to stick in in these fields and
that's that's that would be my my
response to that I don't think we can
really say for example that it's as jf
pointed out you know we we are pretty
sure there's something quite massive
that is pulling things in and it
probably is that the magnet it's the
magnitude is quite large to say that
it's a singularity and to add all these
other additional assumptions I I'm
highly I'm highly skeptical of it but
this is a conceptual issue this has
nothing to do with looking through a
telescope it's got to do with what is a
black hole
first of all and second you know is it
possible is it possible as you just said
that a runaway mass can pull on an
object mass is a concept I need to know
the physical mechanism in fact I said
you folks there can you look at the what
is it the fable of the elephant in the
turtle that'll explain it very well so
which number is that is that the
administration they wanted me yeah
that's 110 110 fable elephant turtle all
right there it is because that
illustrates the problem completely the
fable of the elephant there we go so
what do we have to understand here okay
here here this is the fable says wanders
once there were two camps right there
was a camp of mathematical physicists
and they were the elephants and they did
measurements and calculations and they
only respected one thing and that was
size and among them was the biggest
elephant possible he weighed 30 tonnes
he was twice as big as any of the other
elephants and on the other side of the
river you've got a colony of turtles
right and they were physicists they were
not mathematical physics they were
physicists and you know they were slow
but they were very intelligent and among
them was you know one of the persons
that they one of the Turtles they
respected the most his name was Bill
build the turtle okay so build the
turtle had heard that the elephant the
number one elephant on the other side
his name was Dumbo and since he was so
big everybody knew him as jumbo Dumbo
okay
and the the turtle crosses the river and
goes to the other side and goes to talk
to jumbo Dumbo
and so what happens well to make a long
story short he said look I heard Dumbo
that you claim that you can affect
things from a distance without touching
them and Dumbo says yeah exactly you're
right and he says well how do you do it
by doing through my mass see I have so
much weight I weigh 30 tons and I can
affect things from a distance just
through my mass and he says that so yeah
let me show you
and so Dumbo starts turning around you
know he spins in and the turtle you know
he starts orbiting around the elephant
and so he says he see how I'm doing that
he says I'm doing it only through my
mass it turns out that with Dumbo did
not understand or did not know was that
the turtles had the ability to see in
the ultraviolet range they could see
ultraviolet light and so the turtle
notice real quick that what Dumbo had
done is attach a stick to his shell and
he was throwing him around through the
through you know because of the stick
and so and he could not convince all the
other elephants bad that was the case
because they couldn't see the stick and
so well you know to make a long story
short the story does have a happy ending
a very happy ending because it turns out
that you know some poachers eventually
shot Dumbo they cut off his head and put
it on on their living room wall and he
chopped off his tusks ground them into
ivory dust and sold it on the Chinese
market as you know fertility symbols or
whatever wasn't so like but let me get
the moral of the story the moral story
never believed a Dumbo mathematical
physicist regardless of how jumbo he
claims to be all that comes out of the
mouth of a Dumbo mathematical physicist
is mumbo jumbo you guys are going so
hard on the standard model normally I'm
the one who takes the that the edge
since on this show but I feel like now I
need to stand for the standard model
when we say black holes exist I don't
mean that the singularity in the
Einstein equation is a proper
description of the inner functioning of
a black hole what we mean is that we've
looked at these galaxies and these solar
systems elsewhere and we saw little
stars spinning around a very massive
thing that didn't emit light and we can
guess that this thing is so massive that
it's what we call a black hole we don't
know we don't know everything that goes
on into a black hole but we know that
there are these huge masses often at the
center of galaxies at least and they
attempted that there are stars just
rotating around these things it's not
true absolutely not has nothing mass it
has nothing to do with mass it's got
nothing to do with runaway singularities
infinite mass and you know again we need
a mechanism and mass is not a mechanism
mass is a mathematical concept you
cannot say that I pull on you through
mass I can pull on you with a rope I can
pull on you with a chain with some Ellyn
gated object I cannot pull on you with
mass even if I weigh like you know Dumbo
there he's got runaway mass he cannot
pull on the turtle with mass you gotta
explain the mechanism there is the
gunner of space-time mechanism which
I've sent you there I have an alternate
mechanism of physical mechanism of this
phenomenon you call black hole and you
can see it there built bill can can we
can we agree that mass is at least the
property of the objects we're talking
about absolutely not
mass has nothing nothing nothing
whatsoever to do with a black with a
phenomenon we attribute to black holes
that I can show you if if you put up
there what is it 101 Cygnus x1 101
Cygnus x1 101 Cygnus x1 is it possible I
don't have this because I have one one
one birds beak linear regime yeah but
you have one before
1:01 you don't see that nope because I
have that but that that is illustrate
how they found the first black hole okay
well while I go to make sure that I
don't know that everything from you
maybe maybe we can insert a question the
problem is
do you recognize gravitation I of course
but we need to find out what gravity
what physical object is causing
gravitation that's what we need to
figure out what's the invisible object
that gets in touch with my pen when I
let go of it and compels it to go to the
center of the earth that's what we need
to identify we have to make the
invisible visible and you say that
gravitation is not dependent on mass
absolute well it is dependent on mass
what I'm saying is the mechanism the
physical mechanism has to have some
elongated entity some mediator
why does a parachutist fall to the earth
why doesn't you fall to the earth to the
moon where does he fall to the sky
something is touching the something is
coming in physical contact with the
parachutist and are you presuming so of
course there are mechanisms that does
that predict this there are theories
mathematical artistic theories I would
say but would you this sounds a lot like
the graviton I would say but perhaps
you're alluding to the rope poetry I'm
alluding to the rope of course because
the graviton is a particle and I cannot
pull with particles that's the problem
magnetic physics does everything with
particles and there are no such thing as
particles you cannot produce any
phenomenon of nature you cannot explain
any phenomenon nature you cannot
simulate any with particles all right
well I would say when we get to it when
I I think I think jf is trying to pull
something up but later on I have a video
to show that the a particles is really
hard to deny the existence of particles
but we'll get to that all right so what
I'm missing in terms of pictures I
didn't get any man with everything from
101 to 106 okay well we can do with that
if you look at the Cygnus look at 106
I'm missing everything between 101 and
106 I have 107 if you want to take the
time to send them to me maybe you can I
will be reading one of the reactions of
the crowd while you do that and fizzes
since 10 euros he says what substance
our ropes made of and how can you prove
it and observe it don't try to deflect
the question with [ __ ] about now you
don't need to prove it so we will let
bill get the get is his pictures in
order and then we'll get back to that
question but Peter I wanted to ask you
about what was my conclusion the first
time I talked with bill gayde it is my
impression that there could be such a
thing that reasonable rope properties in
the building of the universe and the way
quantum fields are intermingled with
each other and there could actually be
rope like behavior in the way a photon
just advances linearly through a 3d
space but I feel that quantum field
theory provides this this theoretical
framework whereby you could have little
fields that sometimes they behave more
electoral electrically sometimes they
behave more magnetically and it does
look like a rope when a photon advances
through these fields would you agree I
agree with most of what you said there
are there are certainly many analogues
and it is a it does predict quite a bit
of what we do observe or you can use
something like well that bill gayde has
to describe the same types of physics if
one and there's nothing wrong with that
you know describing the the field theory
instead of using something like
oscillating particles which is what we
do now twisting ropes sort of like a
roto or a rotary dynamics sort of model
it is interesting your I would disagree
with your point about light moving in
straight lines
at the quantum level we didn't we have
that was one of the papers that I sent
to Bill it I don't know if you had
gotten that bunch the first to get your
a bunch well I don't know if bill if jf
did but we do have evidence that
particle light part light does not move
in trajectories that are strictly
straight lines oh so how does it move
I'm curious about this so I guess we
viewed one would need to go back to
firemen's path integral formulation of
quantum mechanics that's what that is
one way to describe it so you can
describe light as moving from point A to
point B along a series of different
paths simultaneously it's not just and
you can restrict the particular paths
that it might go that is why when you
have say your double slit experiment you
shine light on your double your double
slit you'll see a constructive
interference peak right behind the slit
your order peak is will be bent around
your your your slit it that you can't
explain that with a straight line with
straight line paths very interesting one
other thing while Bill get is actually
succeeding at sending me is pictures so
we'll get back to the discussion but one
other thing I was curious about is time
out does quantum physics touch time is
that is that it dimension is that the
property of the things how do we
conceive of time in quantum physics yes
it is a practice to parameter treated
like just like you do in classical
physics it's a it's a it's a coordinate
system like space and time
now how you might interpret that is you
know varies from person to person but
yes it is it is just a coordinate as
basis but it has a special property
that's
at least in some systems view it's
irreversible it's not it's not something
that you can in most cases go backwards
in time as you can go backwards in space
all right so bill it doesn't happen I
don't know I can't get there earth to go
in the other direction
all right so bill before the
interruption what did we want to talk
about we had the 101 Cygnus the okay
this 101 Cygnus what it does is show you
how they supposedly discovered or proved
black holes and that is what you
mentioned earlier a star rolling around
nothing in other words going around in
circles or orbiting a Center in which
there is nothing you're telling me I was
deceived by this YouTube video showing
this orbit oh so we are not am i showing
it yeah there it is okay so this is this
is how they discovered they they went in
there and they saw hte two two six eight
six eight which is Cygnus x1 and they
saw that this star was rolling around
nothing was going to simplify its
orbiting around nothing okay so that's
how they came up with that one right and
they said okay there must be a mass and
they put that mass that black hole there
by hand they just inserted that say it's
got to be mass what else could it be
that was their conclusion okay and then
you can jump to within 106 all right the
Cygnus x1 rope model this is the Rope
model I'm saying this is not done with
mass it's done with magnetism it's a
magnetic field of the of the entire
galaxy that is moving the star around
remember a star is a charged object okay
so all stars are charged all stars have
magnetic fields
and if you look at number 105 baldon
magnetic field dude the stars tend to be
charged negatively or positively well
they charge no your chart remember it's
got a magnetic field I'm talking about
the magnetic field above each bar
now if you look at that there you can
see what happens here on earth we can do
this in the lab you take a charge
whatever a ball and you've put in a
magnetic field and it'll spiral around
that's a black hole right there that's
what's happening what you have is the
magnetic field of the entire galaxy
chopping down on a star and forcing it
to spiral around nothing there is no
mass in the center of that orbit you
have got to be kidding me bill yet
you're telling me that the whole dark
matter thing is like an adjustment that
scientists have been doing but that none
of it relies on gravity it's all a
magnet a big magnet system okay let me
let me show you another bit of evidence
but here I'll give you evidence okay
look at the last one there now where is
it well no it just came on Cygnus no
it's the what is it which one is it the
103 spider web 103 spider web so there
it is
okay I'm saying that all stars are
interconnected they have to be if every
atom in the universe is interconnected
by the ropes so we have electromagnetic
boat ropes binding any two atoms in the
universe that means that all stars are
made out of atoms they're connected to
all other stars think of it as a spider
web that is superimposed upon the
galaxies so now we can see why the stars
on the edge of the galaxy rotate just as
fast or faster than the ones on the
inside first of all and why of galaxy
rotates as a sin
platform it wrote this like a bicycle
wheel in other words it does that's why
you know the problem with the Galaxy
rotation problem that they cannot solve
it is how is it that the stars on the
outside go faster than the ones on the
inside and you can see that in the curve
if you look at the curve there it pretty
much explains what the mathematicians
are looking at it's which one is it it's
the number o six Dark Matter graph o six
Dark Matter graph now you know you can
see what happens there if you look at
the curve it disappeared that there it
is I think we're seeing it right you can
see the kerb
you know the bottom curve is what
predicted what is predicted by Newton
and Einstein's equations instead what
they observe is that the stars on the
outside have a greater speed than the
ones on the inside and they cannot
explain that what they did was if you
look at now 109 dark kilograms
why don't I wear there it is what they
did is they put kilograms mass to cover
the hole they said look there's this
black there's this dark matter that we
cannot see it's invisible but it weighs
a lot just like the black hole in visit
that and they're all conveniently
invisible they all weigh a lot right and
they just put it in there why because
the the mathematicians deal only with
mass that's the only thing that came to
their mind I could produce this effect
and instead you know if if we
interconnect every atom if we can
interconnect every star we can see why
the whole galaxy rotates as a single
platform we don't need to put this false
mass in there this these kilograms
because that doesn't even explain why or
what keeps one star attached to another
star if I put all this mass in there you
know what am i doing I'm just
artificially producing this effect by
saying okay I'm in my equation I'm gonna
be putting all this mass at different
levels
to produce this effect that's the only
way they can do it but then they have to
put the spirit called dark matter just
like a spirit black hole because what
they all want to explain it with mass
this is fascinating Peter what do you
think about this I'm still under shock
of having to divorce from dark matter I
was attached to my little pot of dark
matter
well I okay okay let's let's try to
unpack a little bit of this and it's a
bill is very good at throwing a lot
quite a bit at us but he's a nice guy I
really appreciate it
now when it comes to these magnetic
fields that are spiraling these massive
objects like a charged particle if it is
a magnetic field or what at your or
whatever a similar mechanism that we
call a magnetic field I think we're in
the we're discussing the same thing why
on the small-scale do you have positive
you have positive and negative charged
particles they will spiral in opposite
directions in a magnetic field whereas
on this larger scale you do not have
such a dualistic of effect where you
have spinning clockwise and counter
clockwise based on something like charge
why why doesn't that why wouldn't that
occur on a macroscopic scale well keep
in mind that you know again a star has a
magnetic field and we're talking about a
little tiny and in comparison to the
galaxy a little star has a magnetic
field and what I'm saying that magnetic
field is within a bigger much a gigantic
gigantic magnetic field and it's that
field that's moving that little star
around it's affecting that star sure but
while you can be we don't need the
electricity you see you're referring to
electricity right now you're saying a
charged object when I'm saying that the
stars are charged out down referring to
the fact that it's got a magnetic field
and that a magnetic field can be
affected by the Galactic magnetic field
right but imagine if that magnet that
that magnetic field of that star was say
they're not all going to be all are you
suggesting that all the stars have a
magnetic field pointing in the same
direction the only way that your your
your model might work and I'm not even
convinced that it would at least in
terms of how we define magnetic field to
be if all the magnetic fields who are
aligned then you can have the majority
if not all of the stars spinning in the
same direction if you have say 50% of
the stars having their their magnetic
field spinning flipped then you would
have countered you'd have a mess of
rotation what what well if you take a
magnet all the you know we again you get
a look at what a magnetic field is and
it's the flow of threads if you look at
let me just show this and it'll probably
put it into perspective I'm saying that
I make that what is a magnetic field can
you look at 104 magnetic in magnet in
water alright there it is okay if you
put a magnet in water and you did in
other a few sprinkle iron filings at
random in water and then suddenly you
put a magnet which is what what they've
done here you can see that the iron
filings are collect collective
one-by-one see it's it's gradual it's
not like you know they're there you know
when we do it in dry when we throw I'm
filing sprinkle it over a magnet they're
all there's are all static and you say
okay yeah but here you can see how the
magnet is collecting them gradually one
by one yes point is there is matter like
like James Maxwell said a magnetic field
has matter in motion there's some kind
of exotic matter in motion what I'm
saying those are the threads man the
threads the threads are oriented in such
a way that they force they force every
one of the iron filings to also align
along the magnetic field so you were
right the first time when you were
talking about the Stars
if the Galactic magnetic field is just a
bunch of threads gazillions of threads
sweeping around the inside the center of
the galaxy and out the outs out the
edges it's going to align every star in
the same direction so therefore your
purdue would predict then that no words
we cannot use with this clean your your
claim is that all of the poles all the
North and the South Poles are all
aligned of the different stars in the
galaxy that's the only way it works so I
would think that's the case because you
know again you have to remember you have
to remember that that's what a magnet
does it aligns everything in the north
side you're watching okay so now if I
have say if I throw charged particles at
stars okay and they will have it will
have the same effect or some large
massive charge not a particle but
massively charged part objects say at
then at one say the north part of us of
this star you will be able to detect
which way the these stars are spinning I
can provide a mechanism and say you know
I need a physical mechanism I I don't
want to go in there and say I can
describe it you know with an equation
that's not physics that's mathematics
I'm saying I need a mechanism
I got to show how it is that I
incorporate the black hole together with
the Galactic magnetic field in this case
or the black bow phenomena together with
the Galactic magnetic field and I'm
saying yeah you can do it with red you
don't need mass do we have a way to know
the north and south orientation of any
star that's far from us I don't know no
Wow it's you you need you need a probe
so if you have say a chart like if you
have identifiable objects that are say
charged that are moving near this
magnetic field okay on there which way
it will deflect and then again so you
could send a probe a charged probe
towards these stars now it takes a long
time to do that and I don't think we
actually know some of these massive
objects we it's not easy I could be
wrong but I don't think you can easily
detect at the moment Peter because they
may be able to determine this in this in
this way you keep in mind that they've
discovered these Jets coming out of the
center of galaxies they call them Jets
and they think it's a black hole a
massive black hole in there that is
spitting out material like a geyser okay
that's right they're saying okay and
let's assume that's true let's assume
that we have some object may be a star
or something and it's observed being
coming out of the center of a galaxy
because it's being pushed by something
well then you know that that's the north
side of that galaxy because it's pushing
it outwards and coming you know from the
bottom up in that sense okay so we would
know this is our charge and the spouting
part would be the North Pole but here's
the problem with the elms our go ahead
so I mean I was just saying it then we
would use this matter we would have to
see it get to some star and then we
would know those stars orientation yeah
but jf the problem with this is the
timescales in order to make you do this
experiment or absurd it's not it's
frankly not gonna happen
now you can go ahead but then I just
wanted to say Peter there could be
within the formation of galaxies a
mechanism that aligns the stars maybe at
the beginning they were not all aligned
but by shaking some magnetic field by by
by some sort of inversion you could end
up with all the stars relatively aligned
to a single direction here here's one of
the problems is that magnet
magnetic fields are or electric yeah
magnetic forces or magnetic fields
however you like to put it our law are
not very well long-range interactions as
long as far as we can measure on the
small scale they don't so the in order
to push something to get them all
aligned on such a from at large
distances they would need to be this the
galaxies would need to form very close
all the stars close together for what
you're describing to happen that's why
in you have like a magnet you can get
all the different poles inside the
dipoles inside a magnet all line because
they're all very close together it works
out but you do agree that a galaxy has a
galactic magnetic field I would not say
that the well it's yes I would say that
there are there are charge moving
particles and there are there is what we
call a magnetic field I prefer her
potential I prefer potentials as I said
last time
insert does a galaxy have a magnetic
field it's a yes or no question
not in it's not the drawing the the if
we drove through the field lines it
would not look I don't think it would
look like the way you're quite certain
you would not look the way that you've
drawn you drawn it why not
for one the the field the field lines
aren't aligned the way they are
I don't unless you reinterpret the wave
mech magnetism works on large scales
which we don't see with with when we put
magnets together it does not have such a
strong strength strength far apart the
it's just it just doesn't work oh yes
QED the sun's magnetic field does it
extend beyond Pluto weakly does it it's
a very faint faintly it did how far does
it reach
well it reaches all the way to
interstellar space way beyond shortly
it's very weak so so so now the question
is does a
gal a galactic magnetic field where does
that one extend to does the extent of a
last star or beyond your it's kind of
like asking the butterfly whoops in
Africa that is flapping its wings does
it because the wind influence that is
that blowing my cheek right now I guess
you can say yes it does extend that far
but I'm not don't need to put up a
windshield for that at the moment well I
don't know I'm saying that the galactic
magnetic field extends far beyond far
beyond the last star in the galaxy all
right Peter did you have something to
ask galactic magnetic field is yeah I
mean that it is that far but the stretch
it's not it's not it's not sufficiently
strong that's all I have to say about it
find that we don't need we don't need I
agree with you it's it's not strong out
there it's strong you're not say enough
what you're describing what you're for
what you're predicting it's not strong
enough to strong enough for what what am
I predict for for for things like
magnetic field alignments of these stars
well it's like saying that the iron
filings that go around the magnet are
not affected by the magnet of course
there's a range after that you know if
you pour more and more iron filings
right now at some point the magnetic
fields that gonna reach it no it's more
like two magnets to four very far apart
you're not going to be very close to the
ones going to flip as a response to the
other but if I send the magnet very far
you're not going to one's not going to
flip as a response to the other I agree
you all I'm saying all I'm saying is
that the magnetic field extends way
beyond don't have not seen that that
it's strong out there where it is strong
that it's where it can produce the black
hole phenomenon that's where it will
start around but the magnitude matters I
know you don't like mathematics but the
magnitude the matter the number Christ
matters
I do agree with of course you know where
to to to to say that your your your
model works it matters now model works
what in order for it to works that the
mathematics matters yeah of course you
have this private automatically I don't
disagree you've made a stunning case to
me that okay I could detach myself from
the idea that mass is causing all this
then I would go for magnets but then
there needs to be a whole lot of rope to
generate the kind of magnetic field
you're talking about and as we've seen
in the Jesse Smollett case any any
action that requires a rope leads to
some guy having to go by the rope and we
should have we should have cameras of
people buying that much rope at the
middle of the galaxy how do you get that
many ropes at the centre of your galaxy
if it's not mass quote from Richard
Feynman he was a 1965 Nobel Prize
mathematical physics that there was a
ratio between the magnetic field and the
gravitational field and it's a ratio of
10 to the 47 and he says where there's
such an enormous number come from well
now we know how many threads or how many
ropes there are in the at least in our
galaxy you know maybe there's more but
my plane is saying about mythical the
atoms are there in a galaxy how many
atoms are there in a star so you're
talking about gazillions and gazillions
of ropes of threads those form the
magnetic field also it's not so much
that there's something at the middle
it's the combined effect of all the
atoms in the galaxy that generate this
field the every star generates a field
that extends way beyond the planets like
in our case the solar system the
magnetic field of the Sun extends way
beyond Pluto and just imagine now every
star with that every star has a magnetic
field it contributes to the magnetic
field of the galaxy because it
the magnetic field of the galaxy
originates in this in the magnetic
fields of the stars and so these all
these threads are going up the center of
the galaxy coming on the outside and
they help maintain the integrity of the
entire galaxy while meanwhile all the
stars are interconnected to each other
and that thing the whole thing rotates
like a carousel that's my proposal Peter
what do you think about this it sounds
to me like Ben is suggesting a kind of
self organizing principle whereby
originally D chords and I said magnetic
field could chords in it and could
naturally kind of emerge into a spiral
of aligned structures well yeah I I'm
highly skeptical that this what we call
magnetic fields can sufficiently
describe what Bill is doing is trying to
describe now if on the other hand there
was a secretary type of rope there was
rope gravitational rope and magnetic
rope where the strengths are different
where the number of ropes differ so that
there's maybe more different types of
rope that are connecting for example my
two balls I have not only my electric
rope and by magnetic rope within my
gravitational ropes for example and they
tug at different strengths then I might
be on board but that's not the models
that's not my model is if you twist
those those two around you get one rope
the blue and the red are our threads
okay the blue and the red are threads
the rope is is what the threads do
wonder they're twined around what I'm
saying is the magnetic field is composed
of threads not of ropes but of threads
so it's the threads that are going
around because they're swung around when
you have a line a row of aligned atoms
there are merge these the whole line
swings around and they swing the threads
around
that's a magnetic field it's the
so it's threads around my Rove aligned
atoms that's what we're gonna call a
field and so for people who will
remember our past episode essentially
the magnetic field is one of the tread
the magnetic one right that is being
swung like it children just in a in X in
a school just swinging a rope around his
body that's it and the read stays in the
line of atoms the my my son corrected me
I like his idea better he said both
threads swing around once went around so
they're both swinging around and I think
that's a better model than the model I
originally had in mind which was that
one of the threads comes out I think
both threads really swing around and the
magnetic field is composed of both but
based on the the question from Peter
isn't that a problem that matter seems
to display effects that are both
magnetic in nature and gravitational in
nature given that in your model the same
rope or the same threads are operating
these two effects how do you deal with
the combined effects that are sometimes
gravitational sometimes magnetic when
they both happen to the same atom well
that's again when the when when you have
a magnetic field the rope now you know
this associates itself in other words it
doesn't break it it just the threads
come out they start swinging around but
then because of the because the threads
are swinging around they're pushing
outwards that still maintains the tug
between two atoms that are part of that
magnetic field there's no gravity in the
sense of you know a rope connecting them
but the the fact that the two threads
are pulling out of words during the
spinning of the two threads that already
maintains the integrity of those two
atoms together in other words they don't
fly apart because of that well let's say
let's have two two atoms and a magnet
are they gravitationally attracted to
each other or are you saying that what
what keeps them together is totally
different from what brings the moon
the Sun or the moon to the earth well in
that case in that case I'm saying that
if you have two atoms that are
interconnected by a rope and the Rope
now it starts you know the two threads
come apart and they start swinging
around that maintains the tug between
those two atoms why would they fly apart
I mean why would they well well building
a repeater
show us show us the model one more time
please sure
well bill you know I'm joining in here
let me explain it if you pull them apart
if you pull the two threads apart do the
balls go flying out words no right if I
cut the rope then I will know I'm saying
the three if you pull on the two threads
the balls don't fly apart so they are
still attached to a limited length of
the the cords it's just that the card is
in a different configuration around the
atoms right because what I'm saying is
the threads are now spinning and because
they're spinning they that already Keeks
the two atoms close together it's not
like the two atoms Mountain fly apart
all right now go ahead Peter
so yeah so I I have joined indeed bills
and I wouldn't call it hit what he's
doing necessarily physics I would call
it its topological art and that's where
using geometry without a metric so it's
topology and we're really playing with
art here he makes fantastic videos it's
just so kind of a jab there it's made
sure so then my question is how do we
get these these swinging ropes I guess
my question would be what is the
difference between magnetic matter
matter that generates a field and matter
that doesn't generate what gets it
rolling with the ropes and what gets the
rope detached and starting to generate a
magnetic field
what happen
we have to understand that electricity
I'm fortunate you know I didn't know you
were going to ask that question
otherwise I wouldn't sent you a little
gift there but but this is let's see if
I can explain it you know what is
voltage you know these people don't know
what a voltage is they always explain it
through analogy they say they look if
you get a high spot here in the river
flows to the lower side because there's
a difference in potential that's how
they tell you and you haven't understood
squat because all these did was give you
an analogy of you know maybe a river or
something like that and I'm saying but
what it is is very simple voltage means
clockwise and counterclockwise that's
all that mother nature understands so
you have a row of atoms you have a row
of em right from my end if they turn
clockwise from your end if they turn
counterclockwise even if you turn the
rope in a curve like if you have a wire
right you have electricity flowing
through that wire what is it from my end
from my starting point if they're going
clockwise hopefully by the time you get
to the other end if they're going
counterclockwise and that's what voltage
is okay so so voltage is simply a
spinning clockwise or counterclockwise
of a rope of merged shells electron
shells okay so all these atoms are
interconnected and that's what
electricity is all right so pizza no
bill no I would say to Kurt to to use
your model if you want to define what
voltages is a voltage is if say you're
using two electrons it is emit as a
measure of the stored potential energy
of the system and what we would mean by
that would be the measurement of the
number of twirls or spins in the
particular room I think that would be a
little bit more accurate
counterclockwise would be say positive
and then clockwise would be negative
when you agree with the voltage has
nothing to do with a rope voltage is
atoms both electricity is atoms in other
words you have to have merged shells all
atoms are intricate or are
are merged the shells the electron
shells the outer shell merges with the
guy next to it you have a row of merged
shells and they're all spinning in the
same direction that's electricity
voltage is weather from one end it's
going to be clockwise the other one and
it's going to be counterclockwise it's
not the rope rope the rope does light
its atoms that through electricity and
voltage I would say that no the voltage
the voltage we're talking about the
light the lights that we talk about
light is a is an oscillation it's a wave
of the voltage or the electromagnetic
voltage yeah it's a wave wave is a
concept we can use the word wave wave is
of the world it's it's a wave it would
be a wave of your rope it would be say
you have a you have traveling torch but
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be then it
wouldn't be your atoms if these are your
atoms and then this is your rope they
would be distinct objects I would say
yeah what I'm saying is if you if you
put the model again the two balls are
connected if you touch them touch the
two balls they're just touch them that's
electricity they're both spinning in the
same direction from your left hand from
your yeah from one hand to the other if
they're spinning in clockwise for
example both of them like okay so from
one end it's clockwise from the other
end it's got to be counterclockwise and
that's voltage I'm saying that it's
merged shells or ro bird shells is
electricity and voltage is simply a
stimulus that you give to that row of
merged shells now bill given that you
are talking about merge cells what about
the valence electrons the fact that
copper and gold are good at transmitting
electricity
it does seem like it confirms some sort
of a electron based theory of physics
how do you explain it from the
perspective of the ropes are they just
matters that are more easy to merge well
keep in mind that you know how do they
what is
what is it the molecular orbital theory
they don't use the electron at all they
throw the electron bead away they throw
it in the trash can they forget about
that and they start dealing with what
with orbitals what the hell is an
orbital there's no such monster as an
orbital Norberto is a balloon you can
merge balloon but you cannot merge
trajectories of electron beads which is
what they're doing they're saying look
an orbital is just the region region
which is a concept not in a solid object
it's a region where you can find the
electron bead let me get rid of the
business and now let's merge the shells
let's merge the orbitals and I'm saying
those orbitals that they've been talking
about for a hundred years our actual
shells that are we'd by the the threads
and when to merge two shells merge now
we can have this molecular orbital
theory with objects not with abstract
concepts like you know orbitals there's
no such thing as an orbital orbital is
just a way of saying look we're not
gonna get rid of the bead but we can't
explain
you know molecular orbital theory with
the beads so let's get the beam that is
with you let's do with the orbits well
that's a critique of the standard model
but you still don't have an explanation
why is copper so good and gold so good
at transmitting electric electricity
well we would have to look at the
specific case I can't off the top of my
head just tell you right now you know
this specific case but yeah you bring up
an interesting point Jeff I mean the
only small - I don't mean to be what
you'd like to call autistic about a
thought that's not really autism just
trying to make sure they use the words
correctly it would be conducting
electrons not extra valence electrons
but that's near yeah yeah that's true
moving from one atom to another why
would the electron bead go from one atom
to another well why do money kills a
father is a river why do they get pushed
on the river yeah but listen listen
we're talking about an electron beam
what compels a bead to jump from one
atom to another what because there's
more bead on this side of this there's
less beads on the other side bill and
that doesn't mean that the bead is gonna
go there absolutely not that's magic
that's doing it with spirits what you're
saying is a bead just moves for no
reason nothing touches it nothing comes
in contact with the bead but the beat
simply jumps to another atom why because
because the beads are self rejecting
because one beads is electrically
negative the other bead is electrically
negative it's will naturally flow toward
well there's no beads because the
magnetism will push the beads the the
negative beads away from themselves
physics that's also a mathematical con
that's like saying look we're just gonna
name this one X the other one of Y and X
moves this way because of God and the Y
moves that way because of spirits that's
all some of you saying so a positive
bead to go anywhere unless something
comes in physical contact with the bead
the physical thing that comes into
contact is the intermediate photon or
the intermediate light particle that
interacts between say two electrons now
you call that horrible but that is the
mediator so it is like a dangerous with
particles you're saying that we have a
bead and we have another need a particle
you call a photon and and and how does
this bead so we're just shooting it
right the other one it's like so Brian
Green has a great analogy on this
imagine that you have two a father and a
son and they are two electrons okay and
they both have they're playing baseball
right and they they throwing a photon
which is the ball at each back and forth
between each other
that's the photon and there's a recoil
force that pushes them when they when it
strikes their mitt there's a recoil
force that
them back this is what is the mechanism
how we if you want to be descriptive to
describe how the photon pushes the two
electrons apart and the same type of
mechanism would be used to describe the
interaction between
electrons and nuclei okay using that
same mechanism let's see if you can
continue because that's where quantum
Falls completely on its butt
explain pull now tell me how a quarte
pulls on another throwing a gluon bead
at it a gluon or do we technically
keeper well how about yes you're right
in that we have not a sufficiently you
strive never will with particles I'm not
but but how about a nuclei so a nuclei
and an electron in terms of a pull we
don't need to go to quark so we can talk
about say a nuclei which is a bunch of
protons and neutrons but so something
positively charged and you know like
proton sorry the proton my apologies
built the proton nucleus the the bundle
of particles of of protons and neutrons
is the nuclei and they are throw it
there's so they so yes the the glove
would be different for interaction will
be different for a positive charge
versus a negative charge and it would it
would it would depend back on your your
your your your your your your part
oh this is this is this is more
difficult but yes yeah I admit but
somehow the glove gets sucks back in
which is unphysical at least on our
scale but does that mean that it's not
suppose it's not physical on this the
smaller scale if you then humans humans
cannot conception humans cannot
conceptualize conceptual hair now they
forget about we cannot conceptualize
pull mediated by particles we can
really grabbed me and we cannot explain
how a quark pulls and another quark with
particles period then I'm gonna make it
very easy here because you don't like
bringing the proton and the fact that
it's positively charged two freakin
magnets they pull each other I have mu Q
I would I would have to find them Simon
asked me find them particles you can
never do it you would have to introduce
magic in there the only way you can do
it is like I'm saying the threads are
going around they latch onto another to
each other now you can pull yes but you
can't do a party now that's why we don't
have an explanation to this day of how a
magnet attracts another because you know
you can't do it particles you can't do
with quantum eight a bill I have a
question so this is a more I find this
to be more of a communication style
issue more than something about physics
so you so using reasoning for say
real-world interpretive in reasoning as
opposed to understanding abstractions is
magic
if you cannot even imagine you cannot
conceptualize it it's why if someone
says a positive particle attracts a
negative particle he's introducing
spirits he hasn't said anything bill
bill it sounds like it sounds like that
you cannot conceptualize it no no I want
you to conceptualize it for me how does
the bunch or negative
what does positive means physically
physically you you're but you so
physically in terms of if I go to the
hardware store and ask for something
positive is what you're asking for
I'm saying I'm saying you just gave an
example father throwing a ball to son
right conceptualize for me how father
throws a ball the Sun and pulls on him
there's like I'm gonna conceptualize for
me
so here's he issue so here here here
would be one okay and
that of now the Sun instead of having a
emit
he has a tube okay a tube where the ball
comes in
forget slips around in total twisted
objects that's clear of terms
a curved Helen gated one when that
connects one to the other
no the boys holding it the bullet boys
holding say this tubes around
it's an elongated object between your
two hands that's my point
no no I'm the boy and you're the fear
the you're the father you throw the ball
to me the ball comes into my tube two
twirls around and then just it twirls
around in the tube and gets and pushes
when it hits the end of the tube and
then pulls me towards you
why would it pull towards you it's the
tooth because a photon in this case
would would pull me towards you because
of the - I might need a pick I might
need a drawing for this better than you
introduce the tube that's my question
why did you put a tube so that it could
twirl - but it doesn't need to extend it
doesn't need to extend from one for me
to do I can hold on to the to pull on
you with a curveball can I can you throw
it me and curveball can I pull on you
with a curveball yells and if you if you
I love the Einstein bending of the
universe there could be a curve that
builds back and pushes you back in a
wormhole worm old curveball that would
work no but I mean this is a fundamental
thing that every time I discuss with
Bill we end on this bill rejects the
idea of pulling essentially he says
there is only one way to move object it
is to push them and you can have a rope
of course which will give you the
impression that you're putting but what
you're really
is you are putting on the rope which is
pushing on something which is your grip
under the rope it's I don't know what to
say about this Peter
well I mean because he's four he's
forcing his hand in terms of the
interpretation being a physical
interpretation and in something that we
understand classically that's that's
that's the catch I mean if you but there
are physical mechanisms that I'm trying
to in it's it's silly but you can
illustrate for example you could have a
mechanism where say your ball enters
your the boy is holding this this tube
where the ball enters the tube and then
comes around and then hits the end of
the tube and then once it slaps the end
it pushes him in this direction towards
the father which is on the other side
fooled by push yes so you cannot produce
pull pull the religion of quantum
mechanics no matter how you do it is
that correct you cannot produce pull
monkey-like straight ahead Hank you have
to go through this push mechanism by the
this Casimir effect type of mechanism
where you remove particles or we push
together that's bull
to be honest bill this is actually
something that I scrubbed to there is so
yeah I'm glad you brought the Casimir
effect so Kazmir does the Casimir
effects so for people who don't
understand you have say to charge
neutral plates and then you have a
photon that is not just bouncing back
and forth between the plates but it is
there is elongated photon in bills term
there are normal modes of photons that
interacts inside this plate as opposed
to outside there are more modes of the
photon like sort of harmonics outside
versus the restricted modes inside the
mode and as a result they come together
so in it are there is there so this is
actually quite natural you can imagine
for example two electrons or two
we charged particles in bills in as in
bills example where the photon is
everywhere along the the between the two
particles this is a strength that I
think might have some veracity now I
should mention that up until now but
state between two electrons we have not
observed the Kashmir effects and there
is quite a bit of experimental
speculation in terms of even the
cashmere effect that we've measured with
with metal how do you actually see MIT
following the reason quantum mechanics
has never discovered the photo of the
graviton and never will is that you
cannot produce gravity with particles
period we're done and they never will
they cannot conceptualize they cannot
conceptualize how a pen falls through
the floor with particles what is the
earth throwing particles at the pen I
mean how is it done it's very simple the
pen has to be connected physically
connected to the center of the earth
then we can explain it we can explain
with ropes we cannot exclude with
particles and we never will that's why
quantum 100 years later cannot explain
gravity MIT maybe I'm not I don't think
I I'm not there are a lot of interpret
of course gravity we there are there is
a lot of issues with gravity I won't
deny I'm not in the field of gravity I
should mention by the way that we have
not even observed for small particles
we've never even measured the
gravitational effects on most of these
particles is a very difficult thing we
have never we've never so it's it's it's
it's it's hopeless to some degree in
part because we we cannot we haven't
even say measured yet how if the
electron falls I'm talking about the
invisible subatomic world I'm talking
about just the regular everyday world in
which we live now he's in quantum only
no no no but forget about quantum for a
second I'm
saying general relativity explains the
cosmic world here on earth we have to
explain the falling of a pen to the
table we have to explain it in in
regular terms how does a pen fall to the
table I mean you know here we're talking
about this distance what is it from here
to the table how do we explain that
simple thing how do you explain with
particles you cannot you never will and
that's the problem quantum dies with
gravity what's your position on this
Peter will there be a graviton detected
or do you think that quantum physics
will just get eaten by relativity and
eventually by rote theory there was
jumping the gun to some degree because
even because the prop the problem with
his his framing is that if we're talking
about the pen falling we don't we don't
even have a complete even if you take
aside the gravitational effects of this
pen we don't have we are still working
on completing the the full theory of how
this pen operates by itself we're
talking about a pen in the table that's
the entire system why what why can't
mathematician on earth just explain to
me how this pen falls to the table that
should be very simple in terms of part
in terms of particles I mean you're
talking about on on the clock are you
asking from a quantum point of view
what's wheat so it's kind of like asking
a biologists use cells no use the yeah
use the organelles to describe why when
I chew potatoes it tastes no that's not
even good why some people like okay I
think I think it's it's it's there's too
far of in terms of scales to even
describe its describe it accurate but
Peter is that
like physics should be able to explain
out the pen files that's a simple thing
it should be able to explain it 2,000
years later
not a single mathematician a nerd from
Harvard or from Ambridge can explain how
a pin falls to the table they cannot
explain that simple phenomena that's
ridiculous because this is the simplest
all we have is a pendant a table that's
the entire system if someone cannot
explain that something is terribly wrong
maybe but with ropes every atom is
connected to the table very simple thing
but but but but but we can use a quantum
theory of your ropes if we as I said
with the cashmere effect you know and I
had had forgotten to bring that up last
time but yes if you the the the field
which is describing the the rope or the
the particles moving around between
macroscopic objects you can have some
sort of effective fault but it's it's a
I'm not next I personally cannot explain
it I am NOT I've never looked for in the
literature how does a pen fall so like
I'm out of my wheelhouse here all right
guys I have to leave for one minute but
Peter I wanted you to explain to our
crowd are you familiar with the with
quantized inertia people are asking
questions about this are you familiar
with the concept quantized inertia I am
NOT would you like me to look at a look
it up while you're in any case you guys
can discuss anything you want I'll be
back in a minute bill I don't know if
you had something to add or Peter and
Peter you can you can google quantize
inertia I'll be back in maybe 30 seconds
concepts sort of make simplifying we
make it complicated contract
fringe theory okay - French theory
[Laughter]
Wow guys I'm sorry it's something to do
now quantized inertia from my
understanding I've been viewing a video
about it and quantized inertia would be
a phenomenon by which movement creates
creates event horizons that differ from
your back to your forward so if you look
back there are certain lights that you
will not see but since you're
accelerating in that direction there are
certain lights that you can see more in
front of you in other words you are
losing some some of your event horizon
on the back and you're gaining some on
the forward part did you did you read
about quantized inertia Peter when I was
gone yes
I mean so they so I it's interesting
I'm not a this is very much a meeting of
gee general relativity and light I'm not
much of an expert in general relativity
to be able to to make any educated
comment on this I would only say that
yes check it out because there's a twist
then because they say that there are
photon and anti photon pairs that that
that are born from nothing and they
eliminate and they say it's going to be
different in your backward direction
than in your forward because there are
going to be some events of creation of
matter that will happen more forward
than backward and you see this is this
gives an explanation of inertia there's
more creation of matter in a direction
rather than the other well I would say
there is there are mechanisms by which
inertia can already be explained with
classical electromagnetism rather than
even getting into the crazy quantum in
jackson's electromagnetism a textbook he
actually explains how there's a self
interaction between the lights that is a
mediated out of the the
a charged particle as it's moving and
it's in that light interacts back on
itself and ultimately gives rise to
inertia and you can derive the inertial
mass of objects it seems that this would
be an unnecessary complication now I
would need to try to understand what
would be the mechanism how a an anti
photon would be created this seems a
little bit interesting
all right let's let's talk about it in
the future bill I can clarify something
about this you nurse with you I'll do it
rationally I would do it with irrational
nonsense if you put up 111 birds beak
linear regime can you put that one up
there yep there it is okay if you can
make that a little bigger it would be
great I don't think I can unfortunately
maybe I can try this if every atom from
the Sun is connected to every atom of
Proxima Centauri
that's our nearest star 4.3 light years
away if all these atoms are
interconnected by ropes okay here you
have all the stars in you know as a
given region of the Sun of the sky and
they're all interconnected well if you
have the in that case we have the
enterprise here trying to get out of the
Sun out of the solar system well in the
bird speak area there we would have
gravitation that that can be described
by Newtonian by the Newtonian equation
but when you get into this linear region
which will come up here in a second see
it goes into the linear region and then
you have gravity is not the same in that
region as it was in the bird speech so
now you have inertia in front of you
because what happens is you've exited
the Newtonian region the Newtonian range
which is only in the bird speed that
would explain for example why the
pioneers of slowing down as soon as
the object wants to leave the solar
system it is going to go through that
birds from that bird speak to the linear
region to the linear regime but how can
there be a birds beak if all of the
atoms are linked and linearly they're
limiting you and I are holding many
ropes right in our hands the farther you
get away the more the Burroughs will you
know in the center between us you'll
have a region where all the ropes
converge and act as a single coaxial
that's my point okay it's it's a
physical necessity and so what I'm
saying is gravity the the square root
the the square of the distance factor is
only in the bird speak region of the
solar system once you get in a region
between two stars you get into this
linear region you no longer have the
acceleration that Newton and Einstein
predicted with their equations and
that's why neither one of those
equations can predict why the pioneers
of slowing down they had to invent the
nonsense absolute nonsense that these
prose because of their irregular shapes
they're throwing Heat in front of them
and that's what's slowing them down
towards the Sun but it turns out that
the Cassini probe the Galileo probe
they're all doing the same thing and
they can actually they can't be that all
of them have the same problem with heat
in front of them this is any pro trying
to leave the solar system because every
atom of the probe is tied to the Sun and
because every atom of the Sun is tied to
every atom that makes Proxima Centauri
they would have to go from the bird's
beak into the linear region and slow
down that's that's why that would
explain this inertial deal that this guy
one thing I found myself wondering today
was do you guys you - do you agree with
gravity being proportional and forced to
the square of the distance or do you
think that becomes wrong at certain
scales
in the linear region it's it's not true
so it's not even true when we're close
that it's r-squared it's close to the
Sun it's very cool yeah it is R squared
in in our region we have R squared no
problem it's that you think that when we
get our a that does it get closer to our
or closer to our tree
in other words gravity that the force of
gravity seems to diminish as you get
distant from the object is that
diminishment a square function
Perley and forever up to the end of the
universe or do you think that there that
it's not square only in the birds beak
only in the birds beak Newtonian gravity
and Einstein gravity when you get into
the linear region we no longer have
Newtonian or Einstein Yin gravity it
can't be all right wonderful was that
Peter go ahead I guess besides this is a
too high IQ for me to interpret the
referred Peaks but if we put that to the
side
you jerk to Anthony your question jf
your your chart your the linear your
your model your your question about is
it goes more than 1 over R squared at
larger distances I guess you were
alluding to something like why we
observe black at dark is a alternative
to dark matter interpretations why the
the force goes differently I'm not quite
sure why you have this thought in the
first place that I guess it's emerged
when I was looking at these YouTube
videos about dark matter precisely and
they were like that there was some
missing gravity and I was wondering what
do we know about our the the force of
gravity diminishes with distance I do
know that this it's been the alternate
gravity only where the gravitational
force alters at different distances like
it's a sort of a scalable parameter has
been played with in the past
I don't know exact it's not my expertise
to know exactly why but for the most
the community doesn't doesn't think that
it's a valid and for some reason doesn't
work interpret that as you may was there
anything else you guys wanted to discuss
tonight because I had a clue just pick
tack I have a last reveal that I want to
do to trigger bill I think that by
showing in this image you would go
absolutely insane i I do want to get to
that now but that's exciting to me but
okay after we have time to look at some
of the things that I sent to you or
absolutely let's look into it did I
forget to download them you send them to
my send you links hyperlinks I don't
think they should be oh yeah yeah I
remember I loaded them they're here they
are so what did you want to look at
first so let's take a look at for
example my comment about the black holes
my up my my my one criticism about the
meme sure so here we are saying until we
can feasibly probe black holes at the
length and time scales of their dynamic
behavior they remain a topic of
mathematical speculation that is your
statement yes this is a small brain
interpretation yes and then there's his
Freeman Freeman Dyson who comments on
both Fineman and not firemen sorry
Einstein and I think it's Oppenheimer on
the interpretation of black holes where
he's he is says that they were not
particularly interested but they said
it's a thing of the mathematical beauty
now we have bill gay bill gayde here who
ridicules mathematical physics but for
some reason he proceeds to develop a
theory of that describes what is the
pinnacle of mathematical physics this is
a circle that I quite haven't quite
figured out how to wear yet it's true
bill you are invoking mathematical
concepts
and certainty by referring to the road
the road the pull the push well let's
put it in the proper context the context
is as follows mathematics describes
mathematics has no power to explain
anything any phenomena that's the first
thing we have to but get clear an
equation can only describe the physical
interpretation is the big problem today
we're not we're not contesting we're not
challenging the mathematics we're saying
we need to have a physical
interpretation for how a pen falls to
the floor we need to have a physical
interpretation how a magnet attracts
another we don't have these today so so
the issue have to continue developing
more math the issue is we need to figure
out what the mechanism that mother
nature uses to produce these effects
that's what we're that's what I'm
looking at I'm saying we need to
conceptualize these things we don't need
to observe anything we don't need to
measure anything we don't need to do any
more of that what we need to do is
conceptualize and say how does Mother
Nature perform all these things and if
we're gonna say mass pulls you know the
mass of a black hole pulls on a star
we're using magic we're not explaining
it we're just saying look there's this
when the elephant is very big it pulls
stronger that's all what we're saying
when we say mass we need to have a
physical mechanism it's got to be an
elevated Meccan mediator it cannot be
anything other than an elongated
mediator now and then rope is a good
mediator now bill I actually do as ice
men shinned last time I do agree that a
physical a real interpretation I would
say of what's going on of the dynamics
of what's going on in these
circumstances work so now if jf if you
could pull up the actually just the one
might be good enough for two for today
yep there we go
so this is a real interpretation that
has been we've been play that has been
done in a few labs including Bush's lab
at MIT so if you want to go ahead and
playa from the beginning all right there
it is so now we have these bouncing
balls here a bouncing oil droplets that
you can interpret as say your charged
particles bouncing on your fabric and
that's oil bouncing on water it's oil
it's oil droplets bouncing on oil on a
vibrating disc well and these this has
actually been performed in the lab so
this is quite amazing and they though
that's a fast scan of a much faster
speed bouncing of these of these drop
oil droplets that you see here and the
the key mechanism is that these these
oil droplets when they bounce they
produce the waves and there you have
entangled particles for example but the
key mechanism is about the BET the ball
bounces they here's the mechanism if you
want to pause it for a second
the key mechanism is that the oil
droplet disturbs the the water the oil
around it and produces a vibration or a
wave in the in the shaker and in the in
the in the liquid and then as a result
the the when it comes up and then
bounces down again it's going to move in
a particular direction depending on
where it lands with respect to the waves
that it already created this is
fascinating but this is what is this
meant as a model of what happens in
quantum physics while it doesn't happen
with all right this is a exactly so what
is the oil supposed to be an analogy the
oil ocean the ocean the ocean is is
interpreted to be the the potential the
electromagnetic potential that's our
objects tell me speak not I'm sorry can
you repeat
I don't want you using any word of
mathematics I want you to use physical
object
what is the oil and analogy of what is
the power of the medium the protons
Ifill pants no no we still don't we're
still not talking in the same seam the
first thing you're saying there's this
ball that's going up and down right this
droplet and it's going up and down in
some kind of ocean there you show oh she
knows protons I'm sorry ocean of photons
ocean of photons okay so that means all
these photons are discrete particles am
i right here they can be it can be in
yes I mean you want to get more granular
we don't need to get to be don't need to
get granular here belt button that ocean
of oil are those discrete particles or
are they interconnected that's what I
want to know but photon particle what is
the the medium that surrounds the photon
particles each each fault what is it
surrounded by each each photon particle
the electrons are the oil droplets that
are bouncing yeah and in the in the
ocean I'm concerned about the ocean
forget about the look at this ocean this
magical ocean that you have there it's
magical bill I can go to the hockey book
well isn't a hardware store and get oil
here I'm not sure what the other problem
is quantum it's magical when we say
there's an ocean around an atom or
whatever
what is the medium that keeps an
electron tied to a proton that's what
I'm looking at I'm gonna get at this
feel this this this magical word word
that is used in quantum mechanics this
field is this region in where everything
floats
bill this is a real experiment that was
performed there to get back to it I have
no problem with the experiment I
by this analogy to quantum that's what I
want you to tell me so what is you do
the wave is the electromagnetic
potential there's no such word as
potential in science and that's ok but
what would be like what would you like
to what would I want a tree I want a
rock I want a dog I want a physical
object then event if you if you if you
if you want then we can call it the the
the liquid or liquid in the fabric
liquid you have a two-dimensional you
have this ball floating in in a two
dimensional scenario all right here we
know that we know that you know the the
region around an atom has to be three
dimensional well I mean on the surface
of a mother for example you have for
example charged particles moving around
the surface and you have surface charges
so I mean it's not where not only can
always confined to three dimensions
that's the first thing I should mention
now is that an atom I know you don't
like to abstract bill to conceptualize
this up two lines I need to find out I
need to find out if I have an atom the
region around it it has to be three
dimension right okay so now how do you
put your two dimensional surface after
this three dimensional scenario that's
what I want you to conceptualize for me
this is a difficult thing to do it's not
impossible
so bill in other words you're saying
that Peter and with his R is a good
performance artist but not a physicist
[Laughter]
what happens around an atom or we cannot
say that this oil which is a two
dimensional scenario is what the ether
in the universe is made of or the ether
around an
Adam or whatever the world is
three-dimensional we have to have we
have identified what physical objects
are in that invisible three-dimensional
world this two dimensional scenario
cannot be extrapolated to our
three-dimensional world otherwise you
got to identify that three-dimensional
ocean the problem the problem bill is
that with the oil droplet experiment
we're utilizing gravity a unique way the
the reason why it doesn't it doesn't
work is not because of some missing link
in our system but precisely because we
don't have gravity say for example
working in this way now if we had for
example we used some sort of charged
fluid for example and we use some sort
of background charge for example that
that we it would probably be probably
crazy voltages that you need to apply
inside this three-dimensional sea and
you say charged besides and then shakes
these vibrated the created noise what
created this sort of wave around it
I might imagine that you could or a
bubble of waves around it I'm not it
doesn't it doesn't seem far-fetched to
be able to extend this analogy with
within a physical setup I just wanted to
point this out in that it's very neat
what Bill's developed I just want to
point out that it's actually this is how
I instead of comparing it to the wave
particle waves and particles
I think build ropes are much more suited
to say be compared to oil and bound oil
droplets in terms of where it lies in
the realm of physics so yeah I'm curious
what do you think about Jeff well I mean
I cannot take a conclusion on this
friction case that's why I keep having
Bill arm I there seems to be nothing
that will stop there he can adjust his
explanation to everything and now he's
asking me to leave dark matter and
married the rope it's a tough decision
I'm very emotional with these things I
would say I've never seen any sort of
alternative thinking framework that that
is so malleable to the point of
explaining everything and potentially
more than current physics so that's why
I keep having bail on it it's just it's
stunning and in any case even if it was
wrong it is good thinking that helps the
mind to to try bold IDs and that's what
we need in physics anyway
I do agree with you I do agree with you
there jfi this is one I think we more
people should explore these I would say
heterodox ideas these different but I
would call different ways of
philosophically approaching science as
opposed to the Orthodox pedagogy
I think only then can one advance and
try to understand more about the reality
we live in all right oh yes let me
reread the question here so fizz's was
asking what substance are ropes made of
and how can you prove it and observe it
don't try to deflect a question with
[ __ ] about how you don't need to
prove it well first of all let me
address that last part first in science
we don't prove proof means we convince
you and try to make you believe like I
do so we don't do that in science we
explain for you to understand and then
we leave it at that what you believe is
your own personal business so there's no
proof and I'm not gonna prove to him
anything what I'm gonna do is the father
I'm gonna explain to him what the model
is the model is that a rope is really if
we were to untangle every atom every
rope in the universe we would have a
single closed loop thread okay so I'm
saying the entire matter in the universe
consists of one single closed loop
thread think of it as a
Circle okay that's the best probably oh
yeah okay so there's ultimately that's
all there is in the universe
now this this thread winds around turns
into atoms and ropes that interconnect
the atoms that's it that's all that is
in matter so if we were to unravel every
atom every rope all we would have in the
entire universe is one thread the thread
is an elementary entity an elementary
entity by definition by definition or
fundamental entity is one which is not
made of any constituent parts it's a
single closed loop thread that's made of
a single piece but it has the ability to
be flexible
unlike what we have in our macro world
where we say well if something is made
of a single piece it's not flexing
what's not malleable this thread is made
of a single piece and therefore it's not
made of anything itself because by
definition or or the assumption is that
this thread makes up everything else
okay so that's the answer to his
question Hey hey Bill one thing that we
didn't get to I didn't get to clarify
last perhaps you already did clarify
when you have saved for a particle of
particles here we have rope interacting
with all of them and let's say and this
is the polarization problem that I
didn't quite understand if I start
rotating save two of these particles
yeah with respect to each other do you
predict that when there's gonna be a
kangaroo tangling of these ropes I don't
do predictions sorry no I'm not asking
you can you describe what happens when
when two particles when two particles
over here are rotating yeah are rotating
with you expect to there and there is
another pair over there where there is
ropes connected they're going to get
they're going to get tangled up ah-ha
tangley you wanna you wanna do I want an
answer into tangling bill because of
course now
this question I've got because you know
everybody of course thinks of the
tangley strokes out there don't be
tangle and and the first answer that
that is why did you ask the question in
quantum quantum has the idiocy of a
particle being at two places at once
it's known as D Connor hold it hold it
and then it also has where two particles
can be at the same place
it's called superposition nobody
questions that
well well bill I would say this the wave
if you go back to the interpret to the
the picture that I showed before where
you have a bouncing or droplet where you
have you have the yeah if you notice the
wave is actually dispersed long in
further distance than where the oil
droplet itself is as a result the it can
be in - it can go through the wave
itself can go through both slits to take
the analogy further however the oil
droplet only go through one and the the
result of the wave going through allows
the but the gives additional
possibilities of the where the the oil
drop oil droplet can bounce so I don't
see I don't see a contradiction if you
use that is that you use the magic one
that's where the country which is
where's the wand wand is that you turn
your particle your discrete particle
into a wave to get home okay if there's
no magic picture particles can a
particle be a two places at once that's
a question particle the part we we
describe the particle as the wave as the
way come behind with the the weak matter
wave combined combined with what what
people ordinary just described as
particle wave duality as is the particle
with the wave it's notice it's not fine
but if you want to use in if you if you
want to use a language interpreted
interpreted using what's called pilot
wave theory which is what I was
presenting here and that was a
particular interim ulation the oil
droplet is a physical analogy of it you
have a pop you have a have a particle
in a real physical mediated wave in the
oil the particle is just in one spot but
the wave can be in multiple positions
that's what quantum did they brought in
duality they said look let's just merge
the part of it and when we got explained
this will use the party going when we
want to explain now we'll just use the
wave and that's the problem that's
cheating it's known as cheating because
you don't have a physical interpretation
if you're gonna use the particle as a
way whenever you know it's convenient
that's what well but I hope maybe take a
look at that the oil droplet analogy
further and then maybe you can comment
more on this later I didn't want to
throw I didn't mean to throw this at you
I think there's more to it than you're
eating you're appreciating this
afternoon and again my only question
with that right off of 319 was that you
know you gotta try to interpret you
gotta show what the analogy is of that
two-dimensional up-and-down surface to a
three-dimensional you know solid land
what I call yes but I would say it does
solve the problem that you might have
with particle wave duality to solve that
problem we need to start at language
semantics semantics
yes which are the fills that words me I
didn't I didn't mean to belittle that
last time this is a it's important it's
an important topic but it's it's more
it's not physics it is I would say a a
difficult is a difficult portion of
philosophy and metaphysics of the
physics were describing
I disagree I'm saying we have to
establish the foundations of physics no
one has done that in ten thousand years
nobody knows what physics is about
that's the problem yet is true you're
mixing to do without you you can't do
physics without objects therefore you
need to define for the discipline known
as physics you need to define what
object is and separated from concepts
and method physics only worse with
concepts positive negative waved all
that is nonsense
that has mass you know none of that has
anything to do with physics physics only
works with objects and to that I would
say that you're right in that we do need
to deal with objects there are
difficulties in that we have we've tried
to measure say the shut the size of the
electron and we still haven't figured
out what the sizes I know you have an
answer to that which is actually a
pretty clever one which is why I like
the hypothesis for that reason one one
of the many reasons but I would say you
are mixing metaphysics with physics this
is what I would how I would answer that
it's like don't you need foundations for
physics yes or no it's like it's like
yes you do need foundations but it was
not but it I would but yes yeah you're
absolutely right but the people are
going to have different metaphysics
because physics cannot answer questions
about metaphysics is what I'm going to
say so don't please please stop mixing
it's just like you're mixing a biology
with a biological ism in a sense sort of
the mess of physics of biology let's
let's you want to include both but let's
not mix the two up and say they're the
same thing I'm not saying that we mix
them I'm saying that for per for the way
method physics has developed it develop
along mathematics and today we have this
erroneous view of physics that it's
about mathematics it's not physics
objects and so we have to establish what
physics is about and that's got nothing
to do with metaphysics or philosophy
it's got to do with establishing the
foundations of physics right until you
find out but no I agree I agree with you
there I'm very welcoming of business
view air is that I I agree that that
essentially a science needs to define
what's the subject and it cannot define
two subjects it must start with one
thing that it studies and I for
agree that in physics it's not really
specified I've have never heard it
specified by anyone else
then then himself now but I was
wondering it's passed through my head
but do you think when Lawrence Krauss
says something from nothing that's magic
that's gave a good example I mean is
that physics or are we talking to
religion now well I mean I should you
should keep in mind bill that you meant
you you treat physics as if it's some
sort of uniform block most people most
physicists actually are quite critical
of Lawrence Krauss is liberal use of the
word nothing
I don't mean to suggest otherwise okay
maybe you do because you're closer to
those people I'm not gonna dispute that
I have a different opinion let me tell
you why what reaches the public that's
what I'm concerned about I don't know
what the people I don't do what the
Harvard people think or the Cambridge
people think I want to know what the
public thinks and the public at large
believes black halls as being true and
proven and no chance of ever turning
that back they believe in dark matter
it's presented as proof and truth to
them so the public believes in all these
things and that's what I'm concerned
about
if the mathematician would present it to
the public saying look this is
speculative we don't really know but
that's not the way they present this and
we proven like oh we've seen them we
know they collided and sent gravity they
talk about it as proof and truth and
that's what the public believes that's
it well I completely agree with you here
bill it's kind of a problem of the
squeakiest wheel gets the oil and the
squeaky wheels the mistress scenarios
are a abusing language and they are
abusing concepts and I completely agree
with you there
all right gentlemen we are added toward
our conclusion I will pull my last move
on bill and I will be singing a song
from Rage Against the Machine and and
who was it before Rage Against the
Machine I don't even remember I will be
dancing on the gray
of the rope theory because I'm about to
present a graph that will trigger bill
gayde one two three go here is something
you can't understand here is something
you can't understand I can get a Higgs
boson here is something you can't
understand then I can get 2x boson air
is something you can't understand what
do you have to say to this graph Ben it
was a pleasure
I'll be containing this show alone I
have some news to cover thank you so
much for coming Peter eight if there's
just one thing I would like to say at
the end is I hope that we continue to
put aside petty human squabbles that we
get involved with on a daily basis and I
hope that tonight's discussion helped us
illuminate the truth about the reality
that we can pass on to our future AI or
overlords as predicted by Jeff's new
book the revolutionary phenotype
available on amazon.com near steal thank
you so much thank you for coming bye-bye
all right that was exciting
again these discussions are so
fascinating what is there to say after
this heard our burner says row and he
says that feed when I'm smarter than
these scientists are not Nikitina says
this has completely turned me off of
pursuing any education in physics Jeff I
understand now why you no longer work in
the science industry but I think that
these discussions are fascinating when
we test these these frameworks
personally it's not the kind of
discussion that get me out of academia
it's precisely the contrary it is the
assumption that something is wrong
without proper challenge that is what
hurts me hurts what I
things and stent boxes as these shows
are so much fun Machiavelli's chris says
that Einstein proved time travel is
possible well in a sense yes you can you
can view dilation of time as you can
view dilation of time as a effect time
of a type of time travel but it's just a
type and it's just it just gets you into
the future with respect to other people
who don't travel as fast as you francis
varnak says bill how do you explain heat
mechanistically i think that bill as the
reason i don't take the time to ask is
that it was already getting long and
bill as a a traditional view of heat in
other words is route theory doesn't say
anything special about heat as far as I
know you can you can have you can have
is robes just shaking just having energy
well it's true that he probably wouldn't
use the word energy so maybe I can ask
him next time farm master Ferreira says
thoughts on theoretically using general
relativity to travel forward in time
such as a particle moving at a fraction
of light speed to dilate time yeah it is
it must exist but the question is how
much energy do we can we use to get
there and the big problem is also the
effect of acceleration --all effects of
gravity getting to the speed of light
you you will need to undergo 6 g 7 g
type of acceleration for a long long
time maybe with the frozen body it would
work but the faster you get to the speed
of light the more you have difficulties
because it crushes your body and you
cannot handle more than 1 g in a
prolonged fashion maybe 2 g in extreme
cases but you need to be frozen if you
go for 3 4 5 G's